the philippines is a country made up of
many islands and many peoples it was
named after king philippe ii of spain
when the spanish conquered it in the mid
16th century and despite the islands
winning their independence twice it
never changed its name in the way that
many newly independent countries do
which raises the question why did the
philippines keep its spanish name so
first context at the time of the spanish
conquest the philippines was in no way
united it was made up of many small
independent states ruled by distinct
peoples who spoke different languages
the islands were then mostly united
under spanish rule familiar and they
collectively soon became known as the
philippine islands spain ruled the
philippines from this time all the way
to 1898 which was when a short war broke
out with the united states and to put it
mildly spain didn't do very well in the
conflict this was good news for filipino
rebels who had just been defeated by the
spanish just before the war's outbreak
after declared the creation of the
philippine republic and so with the
spanish defeated by the americans you'd
think that this would be the beginning
of an independent philippines which
could choose its own name but fun fact
no in the treaty of paris the americans
were given control over the philippines
which they could have relinquished
whenever they wanted the problem was
that they didn't want to do that instead
they came to a compromise with the
rebels you shut up and we'll keep the
land shockingly this led to war but the
americans were much better armed and
prepared than the spanish were and thus
after a brutal conflict the philippines
were pacified so did the americans want
to change the name well no because there
was no reason to they had won the
philippines and they intended to keep
the philippines the same went for when
the japanese occupied the islands during
the second world war u.s sovereignty of
the islands was declared over by the
filipino leaders and a new 100 totally
independent republic of the philippines
was declared the americans soon undid
this but after the war was over u.s
leaders soon realized that there was
only two options for the philippines
independence or full stated they opted
for option number one for several
reasons the first was that fighting a
war against imperialist expansion and
then keeping your unwilling colony
seemed a bit hypocritical second the
philippines has largely been
economically ruined by the war and the
us didn't want to pay for all of that
and so all the best and third the people
who lived there wanted to be independent
and by 1946 most americans were done
with being shot at and so as an
independent country with full control
over its destiny surely there were some
who wanted to abandon the name given to
it by its former overlords and there
were the first name proposed was the
tagalog nation which was a big no-no
because the tagalog speaking people were
not a majority in the country the second
proposed name was rosalia named for the
filipino revolutionary jose rizal the
problem with this was that razao was a
controversial character since he
actually wanted the philippines to
remain a spanish colony just with extra
freedoms and thus no there was one last
potential change of name which was
considered in the early 1960s but there
was a catch another country was also
considering the same name and thus began
the most boring race in human history
the first annual legislative sprint to
get a majority in parliament to name
your country malaysia spoiler alert
malaysia won and after this barring the
very recent push to change the name the
philippines just sort of stuck it was a
case of trying to find a name that
everybody could agree on which they
couldn't and so the one that equally
offended everyone remained
i hope you enjoyed this episode and
thank you for watching with a special
thanks to my patrons james bissonette
kelly moneymaker corso wolff jordan
longley adam stalter jerry lamdan marcus
arsenault wyan hockey spencer lightfoot
words about books podcast gustav swan
captain cydog roddy martin common yoon
boogerly wiggily mrs marvin cassow aaron
the white matthew shipley alex schwinn
maggie patzkowski anthony beckett maxon
flaudio the mcwhopper corey turner
spinning three plates copper tone
winston cayward charles the first and
scottish trekkie